[Music]
what's up everybody it's elbow geo 208
coming at you with the iron Lords
podcast dream team today we're going to
be reviewing a new game called hyper jam
brought to you by bit dragon I like to
say thank you to bit dragon for sending
us a copy to review I review this copy
on Xbox one X it's kind of hard to
categorize this shooter hack and slash
Battle Royale style game
it's 80s cyberpunk feel lots of color
lots of lasers the character is a very
fluid jumping around moving from side to
side very fun game to play there's about
eight different maps you can play on all
of them fairly small you're only playing
with two to four players either online
or couch co-op and each map has
different aspects to it
some have waterfalls some have walls
that open some have cover that will
appear for you or floors that will drop
out making each match difficult you play
in three rounds to the death whoever has
the most whoever gets to the most points
wins so you go around at the round and
whoever gets to the most points first
and then survives that next wave ends up
being the victor the coolest part about
this game is probably the cards that you
get ability cards at the beginning each
round some allow you to have different
punches as far as fire or freezing or
you can disorient to do
other players with your attacks or you
can move faster there's a card where you
are gaining health as the match goes on
so you'll just continue to regain your
health and then there's a card that
allows you to I guess be like a Titan so
you have reduced strength or increased
strength rather and reduce fall damage
things like that and all these cards can
be stacked the biggest takeaway from the
cards is that whoever loses the game has
first pick so those first couple of
rounds is more advantageous to not be
the winner because then you'll be able
to get the best pick of the cards those
last matches especially if you have a
p-card stack it's crucial to have like
health stacked a few times so that
you're constantly regaining health or
that you can disorient your other
victims with your attacks because then
as soon as they get hit they can't
though they might just fall off the map
which is very very advantageous if
you're trying to complete the
achievement for winning a match without
using any weapons I was actually able to
get that while reviewing this game and
that was one of my biggest advances for
getting that achievement was to be able
to have that disorient card and the
health card unknown it's a great game
one of the fallbacks I did have with it
was finding an online match at one time
the one time that I did find out online
match it took me about 15 to 20 minutes
to find a person so my best bet with
this game is to do couch co-op or to
have a team of players that you already
know they have this game to be able to
match up with
but it's a lot of fun a lot of fun cool
music cool graphics it's not a
photorealistic game so if that's what
you're looking for this is not that game
for you but I enjoyed it I had a lot of
fun I got through some achievements if
your achievement hunter you're gonna
handle it enjoy this game you'll be able
to knock most of the achievements out in
a few hours and yeah I loved it it was
cool cool game I can't wait to see more
from bit dragon and once again thank you
so much
bit dragon for letting us review this
game for you iron Lords podcast greatly
appreciate your generosity and thank you
everybody for coming to listen to the
review you guys can catch our lures
podcast Sundays check the Twitter follow
everybody it'll be on YouTube Sunday
mornings these guys are on East Coast
time so it's gonna be a little early for
us West Coast people but greatly
appreciate everybody that comes by and
gives us the support thank you again
peace
[Music]